Hey everybody! Welcome back. In the
previous segment we looked at a simple
recursive type
of natural numbers and in this segment
we are going to look at a couple of more
interesting
recursive types. And in particular
I like this type. Remember when we
were doing the parser
we were trying to build a
abstract syntax tree, that
represented the structure of our string
as a tree. But when we were doing parsers,
we didn't know yet
how to define new types, so instead
we computed the value of the expression
as we were parsing.
But with recursive types we can define
an algebraic data type of expressions and
then define various
interesting functions over those
expressions. How would we define
expressions in Haskell? Well, again
we define an abstract base class Expr
and then three concrete subtypes: simple
value
multiplication and addition
of expressions. We can now write that
tree on the previous slide
as follows: we add 1 to
2 times 3. Once we have
expressions like this, we can define
recursive functions
over these expressions. And again they all
follow the same structure. We pattern
match
over each case. You see that here.
You don't have to
look at the definitions yet, just look at
those pattern matches and then we do something
here.
And in this case, when we want to compute
the size of an expression we want to
count
how many values appear in that
expression.
If it is a value, it's 1. Otherwise we
recursively calculate the size of the
left and the right hand side
and add them up. In an
object-oriented language
you would probably make
size into a virtual method of
the expression superclass and then
override
that virtual method in each of the
concrete subtypes.
Here is the evaluator for expressions or
the interpreter.
So what it does is it takes an
expression and calculates the integer
value.
If you already have a value you are done.
Otherwise
you evaluate the left hand side and the
right hand side
and if you happen to have an
addition you add them up
and in case you have a multiplication you
multiply them.
When you look at the structure of those
functions, what you see
is that all they are doing is they are
replacing the constructors
respectively Val, Add and Mul
by other functions. So let's go back here
and check that.
So in this case I replace the
constructor Val
by the constant function 1. Here I
replace the constructor Add
by plus and Mul by plus. And for the
evaluator
we replace this constructor by the
identity
Add by plus and the constructor Mul
by times. And guess what?
If we would define a foldr over
expressions
then we don't have to write 2 recursive
functions. We can do it once
and in that case for example the eval
function
simply reads as follows: we
replace Val, the Val constructor,
by the identity
we replace the Add
constructor by plus and we replace
the multiplication constructor by times.
Next example: binary trees.
Here is a picture of a binary tree.
We will deal with binary trees
that have values in the nodes and values
in the leaves. And that leads to the
following recursive definition.
A Tree is either a Leaf with an integer
or it is a Node with two subtrees and
an integer right there. And
the picture of the previous slide
becomes this:
we had a Node with 5 at the root
and two subnodes, that had a 3
and a 7 respectively
et cetera. So this value here
represents that picture. You see
5, 3, 7
1, 4, 6, 9.
3, 5, 7, 1, 4
6, 9. That sounds like a telephone number.
Just like on expressions we can define
recursive functions on the structure of
binary trees.
For example we can search if a given
integer is present
in this binary tree and then we will
return a boolean.
And we have two cases.
If we have a Leaf, then we check that the
value at the Leaf
is the same as the value that we are
looking for, and that's the result of the
boolean, the recursive invocation.
When we have a Node,
we check whether the value at that Node
is the one we are looking for, or
we check whether the value occurs in the
left subtree
or we check whether it appears
in the right subtree.
But when the integer does not occur in
the tree
we will traverse the whole tree.
That is
the algorithm there.
Now let's look at another function here.
Let's try to find it in a different way.
Let's first say we take the Tree and
we flatten it into a list.
So when we have a Leaf, we return a
singleton list.
When we have a Tree with a left and a
right subtree and a Node
we first flatten the left subtree, we
splice in that
value and then we append the right
subtree.
Now we say that a Tree is a search tree
if when we flatten it into a list, it is
sorted. So our example
is a search tree, because
when we flatten it, we get
a sorted list: [1,3,4,5,6,7,9].
So now we can define
occurs as follows.
If we have a search tree we can check
whether it is a
Leaf. When we have a Node, we check
whether
the values are the same, we return
True.
Now since we know more about the
structure we
only traverse one path down the Tree.
So we don't have to say: if it is not the
same we are checking this
or we are checking that. No, we know
that if
m is less than n, if the number that
we are searching for
is less than the Node here, then we only
have to search in the left subtree.
If this gentlemen here
is larger than n, then we only have to
search
in the right Tree. So now we don't have
to search the whole Tree, because we have
exploited
the fact that the values in the Tree
are in a certain relation and we defined
that relation by saying
when you flatten the Tree the result is
a sorted list.
Happy hacking
and see you next week.